قبعه سوداء عالم مرعب وظلام ها هو بوتين
يظهر يده الاخرى الخفيه القويه جيش غير
جيشه المعروف يضربون تحت الحزام مهماتهم
تفكك دول الاعداء واحاله المدن الى خراب
نبدئهم ان الحروب تبدا داخل جيش العدو نعم
فهناك تكون مهمتهم الرئيسيه يظهرن في
الوقت الذي يحجز فيه الجواسيس ويقوى فيه
الاعداء هم من يبدا الحرب ومن ينهيها انهم
المافيا يا ساده تجار الدم والنار لم يعد
عملهم هو الاتجار بالمخدرات او المتاجره
باعضاء البشر ولم يقتصر عملهم على شغل
العصابات فالمافيا الروسيه هي اليد
الضاربه لبوتين في اوكرانيا حيث بدا عملها
قبل الحرب ولن تنتهي مهمتهم بنهايتها وبكل
الاحوال فاموالهم تزيد ولا تنقص وتقف دوله
قويه وراء ظهورهم عن المافيا الروسيه في
اوكرانيا نتحدث وللقصه بقيه
المافيا لملم اوراقها لتشتت اوكرانيا
عندما كان الجنود الروس يحتشدون في حدود
اوكرانيا كان هناك جيش اخر قد بدا عمله في
الداخل حيث بدات المافيا الروسيه بحربها
ممهده للقوات الروسيه التي ستاتي وكانت
المافيا هي الوحيده في اوكرانيا من تعلم
موعدا اندلاع الحرب لكنها اخفت نفسها جيدا
وما اندلعت الحرب حتى بدات المافيا بنشر
الفوضى في اوكرانيا في واحده من مهامهم
الرئيسيه لترويع الاوكران وتسهيل امور
قوات موسكو القادمه بقوه ها هو شهر يمضي
على الحرب والفوضى قد انتشرت فعلا في
الداخل ازداد الارتباك على الحدود الذي
شهدت دول الجوار الاوكراني لترتبك معها
العديد من الدول الاوروبيه باقتصاداتها
هناك تهيات البيئه الخصبه للمافيا فهذا هو
ملعبها انتشار الجرائم وكان عنصر جذب
لعصابات دوليه من بينها المافيا الايطاليه
خرجت وكاله انسا الايطاليه وقالت ان
المافيا بدات مبكرا للتحرك لاستغلال الحرب
الاوكرانيه لتحقيق مكاسب وصدق قلق متزايد
من قبل مسؤول الامن داخل روما حيث اقدمت
مافيا كوزانوسترا بثقل على تخزين اسلحه
حربيه ومتفجرات كانت معده للبيع خارج
ايطاليا الا ان السلطات الايطاليه تمكنت
من مداهمه مخازن السلاح التي كانت في احد
الاحياء الشعبيه في كتانيا لنعد الى مافيا
بوتان وفي الحقيقه فلا يوجد وصف دقيق
للمافيا الروسيه والكثير ممن تسمى عصابات
المافيا هناك هي ليست روسيه الاصل فهناك
عصابات متوحشه قوقازيه الاصل كالشيشاني
والجورجيين حيث يشبه هؤلاء من حيث نظامهم
الداخلي المافيا الايطاليه ومن اشهر زعماء
المافيا الروسيه الشيشاني
الذي يعني اسمه بالعربيه الطاير المافيا
الروسيه مشهوره بقوه انشطتها فبعد انهيار
الاتحاد السوفيتي ازداد نفوذها
المافيا تخترق الداخل الاوكراني بعد ان
كانت شراره الحرب الروسيه قد انطلقت في
اوكرانيا ومافيا موسكو قد انجزت مهمتها
تساقطت الاراضي الاوكرانيه الواحده بعد
الاخرى بيد قوات الروس لتبادر كييف الى
تحريض المافيا المشتبه في موالاتها لموسكو
والتي ترى فيها طابورا خامسا قد يطعنها في
الظهر في اي وقت وفق تقرير نشرته صحيفه
الفرنسيه لكن كان الفاس قد وقع على الراس
ايها الاوكران لتسارع اجهزه الامن
الاوكرانيه لتتعامل مع شبكات المافيا
القويه التي قدم بعضها من منطقه القوقاز
بعد طردها من جورجيا واستقرارها في مدينه
اوديسا اجهزه الامن الاوكراني اشتبهت في
شخصيات عديده منها رجال اعمال وسياسي ون
مثل الكسندر انجواير وفلاديمير غالاتي
الملقبين بالملاك والكاردينال الاسود وهما
رجل اعمال يعيشان بين لندن واوكرانيا
وتقول انهما يحملان مصيره اوديسا في
راحتيهما فعن اي سيطره نتحدث
تاجر الموت
طائرته متروكه على المدرج بين موسكو وثياب
مخزوناته هائله من الاسلحه جنودهما استغنت
عنهم الدوله فدفعلهم اكثر الضابط السوفيتي
الذي اغتنم الفرصه بعد انهيار الاتحاد انه
رجل المافيا الاول فيكتور بوت من حكمت
عليه الولايات المتحده بالسجن 25 عاما عام
2011 امضى منها اكثر من 11 عاما داخل
اربعه جدران لكن علاقاته وادارته للحروب
لم تتوقف وبعد عده اشهر من حرب روسيا ضد
اوكرانيا استطاعت موسكو اخراجه من سجون
واشنطن ليعود لعمله المفضل تجاره البشر
والشر ليطلق عليه الغرب ملك الحرب او تاجر
الموت وبعد عودته عاده الحياه للقوات
الروسيه في الاراضي الاوكرانيه وعاد
السلاح للتدفق لتنطلق الجيوش بعد تراجع
طويل
فضيحه مدويه
كانت الولايات المتحده قد وضعت اسم تاجر
الموت فيكتور بوت على قائمتها السوداء لكن
بطريقه او باخرى كانت امريكا سوقا مربحا
لباط فيا له من ثعلب ماكر وبعد ان وقعت
واشنطن في المحظور لتكتشف عام 2004 من
خلال معلومات سربت الصحافه البريطانيه
انها كانت تتعامل مع فيكتور الذي تلاحقه
اجهزتها السريه كالذي يضيء بنور جواله
ليبحث عنه حوله
يا لغبائكم كان بوتيو تاجر معهم بشكل
مباشر او من خلال مقاولنا وسطاء في اطار
صفقه موقعه مع قيمتها 60 مليون دولار وذلك
حين كان الامريكانو يعيدون بناء العراق
بعد خطائهم الكارثي هناك عام 2003 كانت
الفضيحه ضخمه ليصبح فيكتور باط هو العدو
الاول الذي تطارده الولايات المتحده بعد
زعيم تنظيم القاعده اسامه بن لادن لكن هذا
العدو في الوقت ذاته هو الشري السري الذي
تتعامل معه الدوله لتضع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه نفسها في موقف محرج جدا نعم لقد
الحت روسيا كثيرا على استعاده تاجير
الحروب بعد والسبب صلاته وعلاقاته بدوائر
القرار والمخابرات العسكريه الروسيه لكن
قيمته الحقيقيه بالنسبه للروس هو رفضه
الدائم للتعاون مع السلطات الامريكيه ولم
يقبل بترغيبهم ولا بتهديدهم رغم سجنه
لاكثر من عقد في زنزانه انفراديه تبعد
الاف الكيلومترات عن بلده بعد ايام قليله
من الافراج عنه في صفقه تبادل اسره بين
روسيا وامريكا ها هو فيكتور لا يكتفي
باداره الحرب لينضم الى السياسه بانضمامه
الى الحزب الليبرالي الديمقراطي الموالي
للكرملين حتى انه قد يسعى للحصول على مقعد
في البرلمان الروسي بحسب صحيفه الجارديان
ليدير المافيا على الارض الاوكرانيه
ويشارك في الحرب السياسيه ضد الغرب من جهه
اخرى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في حاله غليان
واضطراب فسائل الاسلحه التي تقدمها
لاوكرانيا لا تصل جميعها وان وصلت فلا
تستخدم جميعها في الحرب بحسب التقارير
الامريكيه والتي تتحدث عن سوق سوداء
للاسلحه في اوكرانيا لكن ليست جميع
الاسلحه تباع فمن ياخذونها قد يستخدمونها
عوضا عن البيع فهل علمتم من الذي يبيع
الاسلحه الامريكيه والغربيه الواصله
للاوكران
انها المافيا يا اصدقاء لكن من يشتري هذه
الاسلحه قد يكون هو تاجر الحرب وسواء تم
بيع الاسلحه ام تم استخدامها فكل الطرق
تؤدي لنمو وقوه مافيا الروس على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه ولسان حال المافيا يقول
للامريكان هل من مزيد يا اصدقاء